كنت ماشيا في شوارع منطقتي فرايت منظرا
مؤلما منظرا محزنا تراكم القمامات في
الطرقات فوق ذلك رايت اثنين من جيراني هل
يتعانق
يتصافح يتخاصموا كل واحد يقول لا انت اللي
وضعت القمامه تحت بيتي والثاني يقول لا
انت اللي وضعت القمامه في
بيت فقلت مشكله من هذ مشكله من انها مشكله
الجميع ومن يومها اسست ملتقى شباب حنين
الطوعي مديريه تريم يسعى الى تحقيق كثير
من المشاريع ومن اهم هذه المشاريع الذي
تحققنا به مشروع اخذ القمامه من
البيوت بدانا في هذا
المشروع توزيع دعوات الى للمنازل على ان
يوضع القمامه عند البيت عند البيت يتم
اخذها في الصباح لكن مع الاسف كان تفاعل
سته فقط من الشباب ليه تدرون في مشكله
نظرتهم لعامل النظافه عامل النظافه نظرتهم
الراء تحقير تنقيص عامل النظافه رجل بامه
افضل مني وافضل من
غيري استمرينا في هذا المشروع عده شهور
لكن كلفتنا اجره السياره تكلفه السياره
كنا ندفعها تطوعا منا فكرنا في تحسين
المشروع على ان تساهم كل اسره مبلغ 200
ريال فقط مقابل ان ناخذ
القمامه مرتين في الشهر كذلك نوفر لهم
اكياس
قمامه كم تتوقع من الاسار
دفعت واحد بيقول عشر 20 30 اسره اللي دفعت
اسرتين فقط فوق ذلك عادهم يتصلون علي بعد
كل اسبوع ا كانك ما اخذت القمامه القمامه
عن البيت ما اخذت
القمامه صرنا بصدمه كبيره لكن جا حد
التجار واعطانا مبلغ 200 الف وقال استمروا
في
المشروع فكرنا قلنا ليه ما نمول المشروع
من اصل قمامه ايوه نمول المشروع من اصل
قمامه عممنا على جمع الاسر ان تقسم
القمامه الى ثلاثه اكياس الكيس الاول توضع
فيه اي شيء بلاستيك حديد
معدن الكيس الثاني مخلفات الحيوان معروف
عندنا في الوادي الكيس الثالث ما تبقى من
القمامه واحد بيقول طيب خذ القمامه بس ع
اسبوع بالناس قسم ثلاث اكياس له معنى
تمويل المشروع من اصل قمامه
الكيس الاول اللي فيه بلاستيك والحديد كنا
نوديه لصاحب المعدن والبلاستيك نبيعه عليه
تمويل المشروع الكيس الثاني اللي في ما
تبق القمامه تعاقدنا مع سياره البلديه انه
ياخذ القمامه وافق على ذلك قال بشرط انكم
انتم تحملون قمامه وافقنا على ذلك الكيس
الثالث مخلفات الحيوان كنا ناخذه نعطيه
المزارع يخدمه في
الزراعه لكن
مازال هم في بالي وما زال حتى الان هم في
بالي كيف اوصل الى مجتمعي وثقافه الى
مجتمعي يمكن ان نحول القمامه الى ما هو
مفيد حتى التحقت العام الماضي في مدارس بن
محفوظ بال هجرين فاقترحت على مدير المدرسه
بانشا جماعه بحث علمي داخل المدرسه جماعه
بحث علمي داخل المدرسه نعم جماعه بحث علمي
داخل المدرسه لتوسيع مدارك الطلاب كذل
تعلم الطالب انشى بحث من هو صغير فوافق
المدير على ذلك وبدينا في اول مشروع كنت
احلم به مشروع عالمي مشروع معروف عند
الناس كلهم كيف انتاج غاز الميثان من
مخلفات الحيوان عشان نوصل ثقافه لمجتمعي
غاز الميثان من مخلفات
الحيوان بديانا في هذا المشروع
بتجميع المخلفات مع شباب مع
الطلاب بدينا في المشروع مع الطلاب
بتعاونهم
وتكاتفهم لكن كل يوم يجي واحد عندي طالب
المكتبه يقول يا استاذ شي غاز عاد ولا
ماشي شي غاز عاد ولا ماشي قلت اصبر كم
ايام وتشوف لكن بعد 20 يوم كان مفاجاه
وفرحه كبيره عن الطلاب ليه لانهم راوا
الغاز بين اعينهم شي ملموس بينهم
هل شي جديد ماشي جديد لكن عندما راوه
ملموس بين ايديهم جيت الى الطالب وقلت له
اه ش غاز جاوب علي بقناعه ايوه غاز استاذ
لهذا نثبت لطلابنا انهم بامكانهم حل
مشاكلهم بايديهم لنعود الى
المستقبل